on the afternoon of July 23rd 2019 a 26  year old Latoya Thompson walked into a  rent Lobster  but she never quite made it to those  warm cheddar Bay biscuits its Latoya  just missing or was she murdered  she told me her and her boyfriend was  having problems I know he knows them did  he do it I didn't kill her at all I mean  I killed [ __ ] you know my condolences  to her moms and pops I knew something  was up when she came in with the white  boy her acting coach so are you saying  she was having an affair I know damn  snitch it's been almost two months since  Latoya went missing and the cops still  have no lead we are doing everything in  our power to ensure the safe return of  this Lost Toyota this is the case about  Latoya Thompson not a missing vehicle no  further comment at this time  this is looking for Latoya  you